citizens of the
reject Nation it is John and Andrew
Gordon here to check out the 9h hour
Leonardo DiCaprio epic directed by
Alejandro G in yitu it's time for the
Revenant DiCaprio's back in theaters
with killers of the flower Moon so we
figured we' check this out are you
excited Andrew I'm so excited I'm
expecting lots of tracking shots I'm
expecting Leonard DiCaprio to be
incredible I can't wait to see what got
him as Oscar yeah and then some natural
light that's what we like here so leave
a like for Cinema subscribe to the
channel so you know when we got a new
movie reaction for y'all to check out
and since this is a hefty film you know
we're going to be keeping bright and
alert thanks to gfuel our friends
keeping us energized cheers Andrew if
you want to grab yourself some and save
a little bis scratch in the process go
on over to the link in the description
box ping comment use our code reject
Nation save yourself 20% on select tubs
and also thank you to prepper for
cutting these highlights down especially
for a movie like this it is a feat and
we appreciate it and last but certainly
not least if you want to enjoy the full
and complete Revenant experience
alongside Andrew and I see everything
that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com
theal rejects grab your own copy of the
Revenant sync up with us and enjoy along
everything else we got over there we got
reaction highlights and watch alongs for
a whole bunch of different shows and
films it's a good time Andrew Gordita
Crunch are you ready I am ready let's do
nine hours of fun fun fun fun in the
snow here we
[Music]
go I know you want this movie to be
over there goes my theory on tracking
shot the whole
movie it's the tree of
[Music]
life that's a gorgeous
shot wonder if they slowed the frame
rate or if they did
that okay
as long as you can breathe keep
breathing yeah cinematography like the
first two minutes so
good Alejandra and you to film like what
are you going to expect right bir
natural light Birdman that send my I
mean it's like Perfection to
me this is so soothing in an odd way
yeah I'm going to just have this on a
loop later and fall asleep to it I think
Alejandra should just direct some like
nature documentaries do a few planet
Earth installments probably would be
beyond amazing if he did that it a
really cool shot like patient
but yeah he's the master of tracking I'd
love to see Alejandro direct one episode
of Last of Us oh yeah that'd be
cool God feeling so much
tension yeah it's like you're there oh
no we had to do this I was afraid I was
hoping it was humans Andrew the the
Moose is going to be fine all right
they're just protecting it from
predators
[Applause]
yeah at least I didn't see it oh Tom
Hardy hey look who is John of
course when plutes is clean I want you
toop them up real tight we're not doing
no 15 Pelt bails we're doing 30 Pelt
bsal oh man double the production
what are you thinking I'm thinking
whatever it is they hunting out there D
gleon I think it
is a big one we going some help to the
meat back hey will pter Adam Warlock
starting to miss my wife [__] I'm
actually starting to miss your
wife we are men oh my oh snap you get
no my my
God damn right in the fire and into the
frying
pan this is going to be awkward to
explain I think what a
boss God man the editing too really
Snappy places to find Cuts ooh
wow what a
stunt
[Music]
whoa love if this dude just killed Leo
and we follow him the rest of the time
yeah
ohow okay so this is like war movie yeah
dude this is all one shot right now
yeah whoa wow
jeez
Jesus now if we could just get predator
in here I was thinking that too this is
this is the prequel to prey right
yeah
[Music]
get yeah get that teeth acting in there
I guess this is a very accurate
representation of would go down I mean
this is a yeah this is a full scale
Ambush D Bo mus versus
arrows God how did they do all
this this all steady cam or I would love
to watch the behind the scenes though
amazing and I'm like this the smoke
might be CG but even then the fire looks
authentic I
[Music]
don't uh
oh who's got your daughter
still tell me you got some kind of plan
it's called survive Missouri is no good
now while the re's running it you got to
get off this boat oh you want to get off
the
boat then what we going to do huh we
going to take our first and sit out
there amongst the re like a bunch of
goddamn
Ducks only safe thing to do is track a
new course back up on land what I'm
saying is we St on the boat try to
course forward to forward we take our
chances on the waters glass knows this
territory better than the rest of us put
together make eye contact man we already
lost 32 men 33 now they were my menis Jo
I know how many are lost we do like
glass says that's the end of it do not
look like a defiant fellow in any way
nah n this guy falls in line manay p a
robing if we ever get back here pick
them up make sure to mark this place we
leaving a fortune on under these rocks
there's no more room here jeez dude sh
of course tightest you can figure that
gets us around the reef yes sir how long
is it going to take you to get back here
if you find someplace else in the first
place and you boys wonder how to re
manage to get dead drop on us but Mr
glass here was supposed to be looking
out for that very thing on them pawny
buddies H Mr
glass what about his little half son and
what kind of savage you think his mama
was
uhoh I'm saying here the Savage it's
Savage every time they put something in
front of the camera I'm like is this a
wipe is this some kind of editing Stitch
21 dead soldiers more than 40 dead FEA
you and your boy are the only ones get
to walk out alive is kind of a miracle
don't you think H are we sure the boy is
a boy that one guy said he was looking
for his daughter why was he playing with
this little boy's mama H it's Gerald I
need to kill her I'm working on her you
work on it later when I'm done talking
to you look at me Scout that's enough
look at me we only have a couple hours
of light left we got to stash these
pelts and get rid of the boat let's go
we only got a couple hours left to
argue is a lesson I mean he knows the
kind of people he's dealing with here
it's like just like wants to keep him
alive five more
minutes God this poor
kid yeah it's interesting you just asked
how conflicted he was about the raid
that just
happened I am your
daddy so much for the
boat stay east of the gr to those
mountains you cut a week off our trip
lands blone dry up there nothing for the
r to hunt
huh it's the Predator yeah cut to a heat
vision thermal readout I would love to
see dicapri on that but that'll never
happen oh uhoh it's about to become
cocaine
bear oh shazbot
whoa
damn
oh oh my
God
wow oh boy we are doing this
already oh ah they get a bite out of his
shoulder I guess
not who who
jeez this is the more violent version of
Belo
[Music]
wow play dead yeah keep it going
ow let me just crush your kidneys really
quick
here oh God imagine how much pain he's
in that's how he got into character like
this is how much pain he's really in
without that Oscar oh yeah here we go
there's a pelt for
[Applause]
you
oo a that didn't do much
no
oh
a let's get a little
taste you go
sidearm
knife okay so
the oh he's injured look is so good
now let's go bare fight act
three yeah ah
of
course can't say this movie is devoid of
Comedy now we both get to play dead hey
hey there comes
here right in the nick of time boys hey
he's out
here keep
your
come guys don't take get off it's cold
it's keeping me warm yeah the
irony wow
dude get some leeches on this man's
[Music]
stat what about me it's s right Captain
stay here go hold it down I'm sorry Mr
BL I'm so sorry oh my
God just doing the sutures right here
thing to do would be on finish him off
quick yeah of course unless he has a
chance of pulling through oh is that
Luke H oh my God it might be the one who
saved us from the Martians that's right
man International sign of the
donut Bridger go tell the others we'll C
here
tonight
oh I love you
[Music]
son
hey now we are in
prey these negotiations are going swell
I wish I knew how to speak
French
[Music]
this is
awkward land you want to talk about
stolen our way of
life was that DiCaprio's wife she's the
boy's
mom
ocean of that fire is interesting that
was very smart of them to give them some
horses cuz I did not see that ending
will for them they didn't I want
everybody up carrying glass be hard
divide into two groups it's Gerald
jonesman Anderson you Scout up front
damn and they have to and they have to
carry him while trying to stay away and
oh boy talk about every frame of
painting jeez
jeez this is going to weigh them down
having to carry DiCaprio nah dude this
is a strategic boost for them don't let
down
wow they actually shoot this here or is
this like all Canada did they shoot in
can I have no idea they shoot a lot of
stuff in Canada my
friend
upill us fact I think pre shot all of
Canada oh oh so this is probably in
same same region same area I don't know
it could be I
mean oh yeah
no he's burning up Captain you ain't
doing us no hand no favors while let him
go on suffering like
[Laughter]
this
you so sorry I'm
sorry lay that rag over his eyes Mr
Bridger oh they wa I can't do that how
do we get back without him he's the only
one who knows way over his
[Music]
eyes please he won't be a he's
not calm
down yeah you got too much of a heart
there's a $70 bonus from the Rocky
Mountain Fur Company to the two men that
stays back with glass to see this cre
I'll stay me too wow out I'll stay a all
right Mr Bridger feels the same way than
I'll lag behind with him you yeah and
you already lost my shirt to P so I
don't got much choice but to try and
make it up some other
means $300 he to get to go home with
something glasses to be cared for until
understood yeah yeah my word uh sure
your word is worth a bunch I trust him
to be car for as long as necessary and a
proper burial when is time God with that
beard Donald gleon looks like looks so
much like Dad another act
no do not go toward the
light
a little bit of Dances with Wolves Vibes
right
now that's how you got those
scars oh
boy life is flashing
oh
no
wof
oh
oh getting start on that hole he's going
to he's going to put Bruce Wayne in
there right piece of land start pissing
in the wind and you have my permission
to die hey they used the three shs out
in the wilderness ah so that's what the
three shells are used for it's ancient
not
futuristic would be better if you would
to take that last breath yours now for
all of
us AR musley if you like take away the
suffering real quick and easy whenever
has to know that you give up I do that
save your dignity and death yeah all you
got to do is Blink if you want me to do
that save your boy and blink no oh damn
it he's saying I want an Oscar yes if
you want an Oscar
blink you just have to
Blink ever again just once you have to
Blink and I'll and I'll do it oh damn
it maybe he'll forgive your sins you
know maybe he won't command wow
dude where's the son
Creator no wow you okay Jim Jim
help that shot
[Music]
wow come on man get back
there
nothing like a little rage and anguish
to heal those wounds
where's he ain't with you
g no no wow trade one death for the
other there's about 20 of them down B
Creek they're headed this way grab your
[__] and let's go uh what about glass he
a have a problem no more he like cuz
he's on his own no no hold on we made a
promise cat I I'm a proper Buri when the
Thomas need he needs that
rifle
Jesus
Jesus yes shallow
grave oh my God that's why it's called
the Revenant he's going to rise back up
and bury him deep enough Tom Hardy is
Gooding his enemies consume the yeah Tom
Hardy is good at evoking his enemies to
rise I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm
sorry canteen from the book of
saw this is when M hey hey m m heyy what
does that mean
rise oh
boy the acting is so good I just I feel
everything right now I'm sure he does
too like where is my damn
Oscar is that the body his son oh
[Applause]
no I mean damn that was his whole reason
for existing was his
son
oh God he wasn't even that far away yeah
so wait oh how did not catch
wow oh I thought he actually buried
him in the irony he was always checking
him to see if he was
breathing
Who besides didn't we put enough
distance between us and M anyhow well
doesn't read cuz make twice as good time
as we 20 what thought you said you saw
20 re before yeah what you talking about
uhoh uhoh said you saw 20 Reed down by
the creek well yeah 20 dozen it don't
matter I wasn't going exactly hang
around the creek count Brothers now was
I
uh what was you doing down by the creek
all by yourself I'd already brought up
plenty of water well it wasn't good
enough it wasn't the right water I had
to go get my answer me I ask you a
question he's asking these questions now
don't want to ask questions you want to
ask you want to know
asking no it's cuz you were scared
shitless you scared now put your waffle
down the re what are tell me right now
be honest did you see him put your
waffle down did you see the re
no not a single one oh
no you [__] lied to me you lie to
me I had to scare some sens boy boy
glass you're dead Hawk we don't know
about there's no point out of us Don
either you understand God he's so
committed to this Hawk lie
too come
on let's go good lesson
today
[Music]
a that's going to save you later when
someone shoots
you
oh
[Music]
huh the details of just his knuckles how
Bloody they are G wonder what the
significance of the moss in the mouth
is I can't think of a movie where the
camera gets so close to the actors like
this so so often it's really cool yeah
every every scene almost feels like a
miniature play cuz yeah it's just a lot
of like panning and blocking and it
gives this quality like you're an omnis
like the camera is an omniscient
character kind of gazing at all this
[Applause]
stuff oh God is going to CW all the way
to
him says when is Leo going to die the
[Music]
moviea or a mummy risen from the
grave
hey that be fur is uh sure coming in
handy right now yeah jeez
[Music]
man crisp Arrowhead mountain spring
water ah
oh what is wrong
now
ah gunpowder in the wound is that a
thing it must be but like someone in the
comments Enlighten us
yeah come on
man that boy scout training I have made
fire
yes only issue with doing this is
somebody might see it wonder if they had
somebody off camera actually lighting
the fire wouldn't be surprised if oh is
he going to cauterize it yeah buddy
oh wow that's the gunpowder explained oh
my god I've never seen that before
oh my goodness Good Tidings a crow of
course oh so he's going to turn into the
crow yes definitely and he's going to
aving his son's death yeah yeah and he's
going to have a great soundtrack while
he's doing it oh
yes the Cure recorded a brand new song
for just this occasion oh my
God that's kind of Co oh
yum did that crawl out of your throat
wound what was he going to write does he
think they're dead and he's writing it
out of respect or is he going to write
like fit Gerald left me for dead glass
was
here oh
goodness dude the amount of tension in
this
film
oh so cold use the sound of the current
to mask
you
oh thank God he
moved oh
boy you know you got to hand it to the
camera operator too because I'm sure it
was miserable for them as
well you can't see it but they're right
in the thick of
everything oh no some of some of these
water shots look maybe
reversed hey something's floating out
here yeah some Driftwood
MVP that's unbelievable you know planet
Earth is the best production value money
can buy yeah people talk about World
building the big trick is go to the
world yeah that thing's got to weigh
four times its actual weight right now
four times it's dry he's fine all he's
got to do is throw it in the dryer be
ready very soon leave it out in the sun
for a few days these engines Ain't Never
As Dead As y'all think they
are look at them huh they always
steaming our [__] yeah true of course
always them Indians just stealing our
[__] boy yep thieves who do they think
they
are
who's
breathing nobody's allowed to breathe
around me yeah that 360 shot give me
some Dark Knight Christopher NL 360
Vibes oh no uhoh dude just pretend you
didn't see her get back in your tent get
back in your tent go back in there yes
good lad go on boy good lad yeah a will
polter MVP of the movie seriously should
learn his character's name at some point
dude I'm so scared DiCaprio is going to
feel betrayed by him and do some I'm so
scared does seem like the kind of movie
that would make a choice like that it's
like you a that was really sweet damn I
really love wi
pter
oh whoa Sho star did Spielberg direct
this specific shot that's the predator
yes we're about to have a close
encounter oh are they like cow skulls
yeah
something
wow
damn wonder if he's ever going to
actually meet the father of his bride
who was tracking
them
oh oh fish
you lost one of them Scurry on by you oh
oh my god oh going all Golem on it right
now my
precious what a
shot whoa
[Music]
food wow wolves and
buffalo oh
it's the circle of life
circle
life and it moves us
all to an excruciating
death is he able to talk
yet
oh please I've suffered enough pleas I
am at your mercy
what a
shot I prostrate myself before
you
oh I guess people back then just be
eating lots of things raw like you got
fire right here just you know oh
hey with with a nice fresh powder
garnish
God that bear messed him up so bad God I
wonder what kind of research they had to
do to formulate that
makeup oh we got a predator you got a
bear you are
worthy uhoh team
up
that's what his son was
a oh
boy that is a based perspective my guy
team up with this guy seems good for
you yeah come
on buddy
cops yeah there she is wow we did it woo
you ought to be proud of yourself boy
you became a man on this journey we had
yesterday so we uh we managed to dig a
Little Deeper get some rocks on top of
him so the Scavengers could get out of
him it was done right um freaking change
your story that's what we did glad to
hear you pulled your weight Mr Bridger I
knew you would yeah well more pulled his
weight Captain this this man here you
can see how conflicted he is yeah you
can see it all over his face I do uh
assume that the agreed Arrangement did
not change uh fortunately for me it did
not no fortunately for me
look oh my God no sense of morality for
Fitzgerald he just doesn't care I love
the pairing of these two so much Deal or
No Deal Mr Bridger you deserve something
for what you
did thank you thank you Don
Leon
oh wow we all saw the shape glass was in
it was no more to done right
yeah we're all sorry
ug yeah these scenes in particular I'm
like did they add fog or did they really
just find like a a blustery snowy day
like we're going to make sure the
weather is appropriate to shoot these
scenes well no I'm sitting here like
they must have had to have like planned
so much but you can only plan so much
around the weather so like certain
things I'm like were they just like the
weather's right we got to go now shoot
it you
know wow that's amazing
boss
my
god
wow the mount this guy is willing to do
for a stranger too in contrast with
everything we saw before with the the
fur Trappers
like got to heal
him smart damn 15 minutes is from now
he's going to be giving him like a hot
stone massage that sounds amazing after
this you and me we've earned it we've
suffered today and yeah 48
Hours
whoa that looks like some Christian
artwork oh it's working
together
whoa For Whom the belt
TOS oh a a
buddy
Papa oh it's so
sad awaken from your crisis a newly
formed
butterfly
a where's your boy know I hope hope he
didn't leave
him no that's not him is it sure hope
not
uh something
Savages you think the
French
yeah there oh my what's in the pot some
stew right about now it's pepper pot's
head
what's in the
[Music]
P the moon
Forest oh
boy oh if he had enough strength I'd say
get in there and save her is that
her this is
disgusting oh no no no no no no no no no
no
no get the horse in there do a John Wick
kick oh oh my God G kill this guy yes
kill this
man shoot him in the butt that's going
to make a lot of noise I would just hit
him over the head so to avoid
[Music]
noise my have the tables have turned
yeah please go for it man pants are
still down doesn't deserve to have
those
h no no stay over
there oh
yeah yep oh she did it she did
it oh boy that was satisfying yeah good
luck without your horses oh no the
canteen smart and logical Choice they're
always so good at framing the Sun
NOP
no oh do you think no no no no no that
wasn't cuz they provided that woman to
the French guys right that that couldn't
have been the woman that they're looking
for not sure you you might be right oh
damn whoa
whoa oh no oh
no yes wow nice
nice quality stunt put your hips into it
man where where do you
[Music]
[Applause]
go I love this slow panning in yeah
quite the
shot my man's still kicking I don't
think the horse is okay
though so far it's been pretty good
about
that
buddy poor buddy it was such a beautiful
horse too is in nice
colors oh my God is he going to climb in
there it may smell bad kid but it'll
keep you warm of course I understood
that reference get this man of
lightsaber he's repairing and fixing the
horse course right of course he's doing
a surgery yeah he's a veterinarian when
he's not out here doing the Pelt game
yeah
wow wow that is
convincing oh I know Leo's
dedicated this is what it takes to win
an Oscar you have to jump inside of a a
non-living horse yeah wow
wow oh my God
this is not something I thought I would
ever quite see I don't like Tom Hardy's
chance or Fitzgerald's chances of
survival I mean this guy is doing
whatever it
takes oh it's fro over wow dude how did
they do these Prosthetics and special
effects practical effects are incredible
I hope that's practical effects part of
me is like did they get a real carcass
for
[Music]
this it's Gerald ah
damn if only someone had a chance of
ever finding that you never know you
never know one day
maybe good Captain something to eat
please who comes out price uh-oh I I
have no money then you don't eat things
see how that works maybe you could give
back some of them stol Pelt you buy from
the engine not now johnes Sil
Sil oh is he one of the Frenchmen my
friend he died in the snow and the
other I
see I'll give you a PIR oh oh he got the
C the
canteen Smoking Gun he he Dro it in in
the snow he came to say he Dro it I
don't know I don't see oh he he knows
now he's could be H yeah could be well
offed maybe it was damn that takes away
the element of surprise he's already
starting to sweat Anderson you stay here
yes sir Fe him and watch him I'll get
you a
drink
damn not once in this whole film has he
looked worried for a second until this
moment yeah look at that light
that is
beautiful you oh
no oh
no Jes Christ he is the
Revenant where is
he got Jones take it go oh my God take
Bridger take Bridger oh man do you think
Fitzgerald scurried away don't do
anything bad to Bridger I I wouldn't be
surprised whatsoever Fitzgerald where
did he go Captain I swear to God I got
Tomy Tomy cxas and he start talking to
have property a de some piece of
land this guy
[Music]
Australian yeah yeah I would imagine
he's going to want to go on that Revenge
trip with the glass oh yeah I take wter
too well congratulations glass you made
it here um you know about Fitzgerald hey
uh
so he's not here oh
no dude it's not his fault oh
buddy the cage take the cage hang
alongside him I dude he didn't take the
money remember yeah bridger's telling
the truth truth it'sit Gerald Li do him
he was just following
orders good thank you is that what
happened he killed Hawk a I need a horse
and a gun no you need rest and something
to eat I'm going after him
no wait till the morning and a day Head
Start he'll get away no he won't he's
afraid he knows how far I came for
him that's a great line I can't let you
go back out there no I ain't afraid to
die
anymore yeah buddy as long as as long as
he dies
first ah wish they were taking well
poter as
well maybe he'll join up out of guilt
set the record right I just feel like he
deserves a little Revenge too no more
than a mile up that way going to head up
to the West go down the East see if we
can find some tracks damn dog you are a
good tracker and if it's the re the turn
right back around and meet me back here
I hope Donald Gleason doesn't get it
yeah creating the opening for Leo to get
the drop on
Fitzgerald are
we he's been here
recently oh no I'm not liking
[Music]
this all
right I wouldn't expect to find a man
your stature so far away from his stove
on a morning as cold as this Captain you
uh you
lost take you back to Fort kowa where
you will be tried for murder I ain't
crazy about your plan aside I got one of
my own
sure
oh follow it damn it
for
wow oh de scalp him wow
dude nice cover but also oh boy and we
get an avalanche hell
[Music]
yes
a
oh yes this is how I wanted this to
end a damn
it oh use the wood dead way dead boy
already did that with the
bear oh he used he used Domino's body
yeah ring around a Revenant let him in
yes yeah
okay that was very
rewarding no come on come on get him oh
get
[Music]
him playing tag you're it
now
yeah now it's the
hunted
um dude there's so much suspense and
tension right
now
oh
yeah get over here come on come on you
know this is kind of like the uh
scorpion fight with Johnny Cage that's
why I made that reference in the woods
yeah just with
snow and now all the percussion
like
a got your head anymore boy yes come
on oh no no no no no oh this freaking
musket D scalp him scalp him scalp him
is he feeling the his wounds
yeah yeah that's right I try to tell
your boy all right I tried to tell him
what was happening but he won't listen
and he kept on screaming he was going to
get everybody kill course this guy's
going to run his mouth now you and me we
had a deal that was no deal you killed
my boy God those lips maybe you should
rais man say some girly little [__] oh
dude later excellent excellent no don't
let your rage
[Applause]
CL he got his
fingers how is he not in yelling come on
man blood will warm me up a little
[Music]
bit come on for the love of
God Jesus
no yeah yeah come on ug
oh no no no don't don't you
dare we've come all this way come
on nothing here Mike Tyson him got Mike
Tyson o yeah come on come
[Applause]
on
yes
oh how does he still have energy grab
your Tomahawk grab your
Tomahawk oh my
god dude this is so
painful you came all this wait just for
your revenge huh yes cuz you deserve it
cuz there ain't nothing going to bring
your boy back
ah God just the worst till the very very
end oh
no oh is she going to point out that he
saved me oh maybe you can go live with
them
now away I mean I still got my revenge
but oh yeah dump him in the
river give him to the
elements
oh
no oh Jesus they're going to finish it
they're going to finish the job
oh yeah we don't even need to see just
hearing it is much better
oh good looking out back there one of us
one of us one of us
a
a go to
her this is not your
[Music]
time oh wow staring into our souls
there's a couple times we've heard him
breathing oh my goodness well done I
love that he just looks at us at the end
like what did you think the moral of the
story was do you guys you guys think I
deserve an Oscar now I'm looking at you
Academy am I enough for you yeah am I
Talent oh my goodness gracious I I'm I'm
going to look up theact definition of
the word revenant quick but Andrew first
thoughts um well first of all I Now
understand sucked right so one of the
worst so poorly made that is oh Brett
Ratner um my man it's time bring him
back that was ratpack um definitely one
of the worst cinematography I've ever
seen in a film uh seriously just from a
cinematography standpoint uh every shot
was so meticulous so wonderfully crafted
I mean I'm going to talk about other
things that I was obsessed with with
this film but I was one of the most
gorgeously shot films I've ever seen and
I mean I felt that way too about Birdman
2 I mean the levels of
difficulty that this film like just in
took to make I mean just from the
standpoint of just how they were
shooting with outside with the weather
conditions and just the way they frame
sequences with the action sequences and
and whatnot but the way they they shot
everything it was so impressive like the
storyline could have been terrible the
acting could have been terrible but just
the cinematography was something to
behold oh yeah I was just so
appreciative and what they were able to
do was unbelievable like that is some of
the best cinematography I have ever seen
I don't care if this is a f like coming
off this fresh and I just watched this I
don't care that's some of the best
cinematography I've ever seen that's
first of
all uh but the performance by I mean
everyone was fantastic in this I don't
want to give anyone any shortcomings uh
Leo though was unbelievable I mean there
were sequences where he didn't do any
talking he had to OTE through body
language so much of the movie he's not
talking like so so much all body
language facial expr was that was a very
powerful performance and you know the
levels that he had to go through in this
movie of survival was just so impressive
to see his character and what he was
going through and again I I'm not the
the biggest fan of you know darkening of
the Soul through Revenge but what this
character had to go through to survive
to get his revenge and and I love the
arc he goes through at the end you know
about uh where he just kind of how he
just throws uh Fitzgerald into the the
river and doesn't technically get his
revenge uh himself he does he has his
cake and eats it too I know I know to be
certain yeah I I just mean I just mean
through his own his own uh hands
particular but he lets go of it
eventually he lets go yeah I just think
that was a I just think that was an
appro like from a writing perspective I
think that was an appropriate uh ending
in terms of uh for his character's
progression and Arc um but I his
performance uh obviously I really think
he should have gotten an Oscar before
this but he he really did deserve it for
this now I I have not seen everyone
else's performances for best actor uh
the year of 2015 but Leo was phenomenal
in this film oh sure I mean I'm still on
that Hill dying I'm still trying to die
on that hill of I think he should have
won for Jen go um and and certainly like
this is a movie where he is absolutely
worthy of that award and it is very much
like you know look at just how dedicated
I am to the physicality of this to
weathering the elements um and I can't
take anything away from that you know
this this is one of those movies where I
feel like they finally gave it to him
after so long their other performance
like to me it's funny like Leo can't
take anything away from him he's
terrific in this movie absolutely 100%
to me like the performance of the movie
was Tom Hardy uh because he does have a
different amount to do and he does slip
so deeply and effortlessly into that
character it's weird it's like you know
you're kind of I'm aware of Tom Hardy
just because I'm aware of how good he is
at embodying an accent embodying a
wholly different kind of person and uh
and here like you know again I thought
Leo was terrific but you know I'm still
aware of what's Happening here in a
sense and that's just my own personal
thing again I'm not trying to take
anything away or complain or anything
like you know great great work
absolutely and I do appreciate yeah that
by the end you know he he kind of gets
to let go and we leave off in that
ambiguous place of it doesn't really
matter if we see where he goes from here
it's done he can probably just die out
in the snow now if he wants to or you
know go back to whatever is left of life
for him now that everything is gone yeah
um including his ear yeah I also think
it's funny that they're recommending us
watch jigsaw now after this they must
have been listen doesn't make saw jokes
during exactly um but yeah no this was
really impressive in terms of just
construction overall and pacing too
because I mean this is a thick movie
it's a hefty movie and uh I I wasn't
really concerned for the time at all I
was always kind of just along for the
ride and amidst the elements and
certainly cinematically speaking like
there are a number of different kinds of
movies that will attempt to do this we
were Jing about prey even or predator
and you watch something like prey and
that's a movie that does bother to like
put you in the elements but this is like
yeah to a holy further degree a more
sort of you know Cinema degree where it
is about like no yeah we have a camera
we've got some they used a lot of wide
angle lenses so you can really soak up
the scenery you can feel the cold you
can feel the wind you can feel how harsh
everything is and yeah and the makeups
and everything like that you know just
sort of unbelievable yeah
continually getting worse and worse
throughout the movie for him as you know
his lips are crusting over and he's got
all these wounds and stuff like that um
yeah this was really tangible and
impressive just yeah in terms of like
God how much time and effort it must
have taken to schedule all this and
using from what I understand mostly if
not all natural light like how much
planning that would be and also how at
the mercy you are um how how much of the
element
at the mercy of the elements you are
because you know you got to get the
right light you got to get the right
conditions I imagine there were probably
times where they were like quick you
know start the camera we got to get this
now yeah um and I don't know if they
shot this on on film or not but either
way regardless like the photography the
settings uh just absolutely breathtaking
across like it's funny you could paint
out all the actors and just have like
this beautiful Showcase of planet Earth
right here
um and then yeah you know just the
attention to detail and I'm not like an
expert on this period of
History uh and and you know what America
was like at this time but this felt well
lived in it felt well researched for the
most part and and yeah like the Revenant
is a very fitting
title um because it is all about just
like a guy you know who was presumed
lost returning after so long presumed
Dead returning after so long and it's
like it in a way it it is such a thick
undertaking and it it is such an
amalgamation of different aspects of
movie Magic all coming together um but
at the end of the day it's also like a
very simple straightforward kind of
classic tale um which you know I just
thought was interesting it's very matter
of fact um you know and we're following
this guy obviously who has a kind of
dances of Dances with Wolves esque
position in the story just because he is
sympathetic toward uh the various native
tribes around and he's not I mean you
know he is like the most aside from
maybe Donald Gleason but even then you
get glimpses into his attitudes that
suggests that yeah towards certain
people he's probably not very tolerant
so you know like Leo is your def facto
like he's kind of the best of the white
guys here um but you know I thought that
worked for the tale that this is and I
really liked the various um you know
Native American characters who would pop
in and out of the story
especially that one interlude where he
is traveling with the guy who you know
helps him you know back from the brink
of death only to then be hanged like you
know there's a lot of that uh that harsh
poetry of you know desolation and you
know just the way in which this universe
isn't going to reward you for doing the
right thing necessarily because it is a
harsh world and everyone to a degree has
to be kind of out for themselves and has
to you know take care of their own you
know at risk of losing that much more
you know yeah well also too when you're
talking about like the best of the white
guys too I really loved uh will polter's
character too because like I mean when
they went to that Village that was
burned down and he saw the one Native
American woman that was still alive you
know and he left her some food and stuff
like that so he was a very he was very
sympathetic towards her so I I really
like that character too and I love that
uh Leo or class when he uh like he was
able too I was really worried I was so
glad I was uh so bad at my predictions
film partly on location in Alberta
Canada yeah now for sure knew it yeah is
that where they filmed prey as well I
bet I think I'll have to double check
yeah but I was really I was really happy
in terms of the storyline that when H
Glass returned he was able to clear
Hawkins and knew that he wasn't I
believe name Bridger sorry sorry uh he
was able to uh thank you he was able to
clear his name and didn't harm him in
any way cuz he didn't deserve I mean was
spur the moment kind of thing he was
just like panicked in the moment and
also too once uh Tom Hardy or uh
Fitzgerald explained uh you know that
that story about the squirrel and the
guy and was like all right this dude is
uh unhinged and I cannot mess around
with this man oh yeah that's a that's a
great monologue to that very very well
sums that character up and and just how
little is actually sacred to this guy
like this guy is like I am my own God I
am the only person really in the world
and every situation is subject to my
finesse and my needs yeah for sure I
thought this movie also did such a great
job like everything I mean whether it
was the weather conditions or the
violence you felt everything yeah I mean
just from the opening sequence of that
battle I mean the tracking shots alone
were beyond amazing but every Bon and
arrow that went through every hit you
just again you just feel everything like
you said feels so lived in and you know
and I love that you said like it was
like almost like a pseudo character the
the camera like how close all the
characters were getting in the camera
and then you had that one shot too where
glass was breathing and it actually
would hit the uh the camera his bre I
don't I don't think I've ever I mean if
I have seen that I can't it's not coming
the you know to top of mind right now
but that was one of the that was rare to
see um to my my recollection so I mean
really sells it yeah but uh some of
those I I don't know how the hell they
did those battle sequence or that
especially that beginning one I mean
that was so impressive to start the film
and that and like all right this is
really building up the tone for this
film um I know there wasn't a ton of
battle sequences in this but when they
did get to it it really counted but yeah
it it
doesn't I didn't notice in a counting
kind of way it's just like when you know
a battle or a fight or something should
break out it feels very natural the rest
of the time there're still tension their
still mood oh yeah and yeah the way they
not only the way they exposed and
photographed everything but yeah the way
they often most of the time with a
couple exceptions kept you in a very
human perspective where it's almost like
the camera yeah is like a neck craning
around just to see sort of like an
invisible person to establish the the
area the lay of the land the stakes and
all that stuff and so yeah like I I
would be again fascinated to know um how
they conce of and blocked all of the
like this just seems like it had to have
taken so much preparation and and
practice um and yeah like I like the
music quite a bit as well like not too
intrusive but really well placed and at
times when you need to be noticing it I
thought they did a nice job choosing
those and there were a few different
like composer credits and different song
credits and stuff so like I feel like
they they did an interesting job
sourcing all those sounds and uh yeah
like there's a lot of Great Performances
across this to in The Ensemble and I do
appreciate that it does kind of feel
like an older kind of movie in that
sense too where it's like you have your
couple main players who are sort of the
show but everybody you know is
contributing to again that lived in
feeling you've got so many character
actors not just Donald gleon and will
polter but you've got you know this this
further you know Donald GLE reminded me
of when he had the beard was uh the
podcast guy from the first Halloween
reboot in 2018 he look just like that
guy um but yeah like say something
exactly that's who he was reminding me
of what is that name yes yes I was
trying to think in my head like who is
John trying to talk I'm thinking in my
head like I'm trying to figure it out
for you I'm like I was like I wish I had
a name even to hypothesize that that
makes sense though but yeah and it's a
movie that um you know it's got all that
starkness and that kind of you know this
slots well in you know that Pantheon of
these neow westerns uh you know such
that like you know the Cohen Brothers or
Paul Thomas Anderson might make but with
its own again very distinct sense of
tangibility and feeling and place and
whereas those movies uh or you know
whereas various other movies you know
strike the balance differently
between Magic in terms of the the I
don't know just like the tone of the
universe this feels again very Stark
very naturalistic and for the most part
I thought they kept the stakes and the
events pretty grounded the only time
where it threatened to break my
believability was when he ran off the
cliff when he's on the horse getting
attacked by the Yeah by the um tribe and
he like runs straight off and part of me
was like okay did you land in in the
tree and I know the tree would break his
fall he's like on the ground tree did
break his fall and then he hit and I
think the hor I again I I don't cuz it
happened so quickly I believe the horse
did not hit the tree and the horse was
to the left of the tree and and glass
did hit the tree and got that's what
broke his fall he's just meant to
survive so he can get his revenge and
and I kind of forgave it for that reason
specifically it was like okay this guy
is just so determined but yeah that that
was the one moment I kind of threatened
to be pulled out by just like ah you
know after everything you fell off a
cliff down a tree but but other than
that like all the stunts and stuff like
that the bear attack obviously is pretty
breathtaking but that oh God and harsh
yeah no I I'd heard I I'd known about
that I mean obviously we'd never seen
the movie but I had known about that
bear attack I didn't realize it was so
early on in the film I was surprised by
that um but yeah that was brutal my
goodness heard I heard two vague things
about this movie and you guys can
clarify cuz I don't like the first one
was bar attack there's some crazy bear
scene one Oscars for it the other thing
was I don't know if this is true I think
they maybe got like an actual carcass or
something for him to crawl inside or
something like that or or if they didn't
they recreated one very realistically or
something again the Prosthetics and the
Practical effects yeah they were really
amazing like very convincing if they
were yeah if they were not teeth tee
yeah if they were not real like the the
car and also like when he grabbed the
fish out of the water and he just
started eating it raw I mean the way
started bleeding I'm like this is
there's moments are convincing this is
extremely con how I'm extremely
impressed right now so I mean yeah
that's why I said like it it feels so
real uh so lived in so authentic you
know as we were watching this so um and
I mean there there are certain little
things too i' I'd be very curious to go
back and look at cuz there were certain
of those moments like in the water where
I'm like oh it looks like maybe they're
reversing some of this footage or
they're playing with frame rates on some
of this footage and that was a joke I
was Mak and I hope I don't spoil
Anaconda for you I
know but there is one shot in that film
where it's it's like a famous thing in
that movie where um there's a waterfall
that's going like upward it's like a
reverse shot so when you do eventually
watch that a masterpiece of a film it's
actually a very it's actually a very
entertaining film um it's not good or
anything but it's entertaining um but
you you'll see the uh the waterfall is
kind of going it's like a reverse shot
it's very funny but you know interesting
about tomart by the way there was a
moment too when we were reacting I was
just talking about this thing that Tom
Hart obviously any good actor can do is
he's able to just emote so well with his
eyes uh there were two scenes there was
one the one that monologue you were
talking about where you know the
squirrel with the guy like just how
unhinged he was and also when he found
out that with the uh the jigsaw or the
uh Cantina when he realized that glass
was still alive and you saw that level
of fear like you just cannot teach that
level of
acting watch the wheels immediately
start to spin like how am I going to
cover this up how am I going to spin
this and that's why he was so good also
his Bane because he's got this thing
covering his mouth and he's got to act
with his eyes I mean Dunkirk like
there's so many yeah he always has this
he's so good at that like yeah when you
need an actor to just with his their
eyes like Tom Hardy is your guy and he
just again just nailed in and I I love
that accent he had throughout the film
too no that is like and and that like I
know people you know you talk to people
from various parts of the country and
one thing you'll start to learn is like
oh you know there are a lot of American
accents and especially Midwestern and
Southern Accents that people don't get
right or lumped together or will miss
region so I I'd be curious about this
movie in those terms as well as you know
in terms of how it portrayed Native
Americans and stuff like that but but
yeah like his accent is so specific and
so Regional and again clearly so
consistent like I I don't know exactly
where they established him being from if
it was I know they said he was going to
Texas I don't know from there but uh but
yeah that that was a terrific uh
linguistic work and obviously I I hated
what what he was trying to do to Glass
um cuz he but I understood where he was
coming from even though I disagreed with
what he was doing in ter Captain
pragmatism
wor it's all no I mean like you said
he's just all about you know survival
and he's got a uh a what did you say uh
like a malevolent malevolent quality of
survival Instinct in him again I the
ultimate Cutthroat yeah yeah like it's
only about me I'm just going to do
anything I can to survive um which again
I I I understand I don't agree with it
um but I understood like I mean they
made his uh his character very clear um
so but I think that's the ultimate sign
of a good antagonist you know you
understand their motivation so um but
yeah but I think that just makes you
know it all the more satisfying when cuz
we were like rooting all film like I
don't care if glass has to crawl all the
way to him all film so it just made it
that much more satisfying and I also one
last thing I want to say it was such a
satisfying and such a cool way that he
got him to uh that whole disguise of
having D gleon with the wood we thought
like what's he doing with the wood here
is he building a fire with
cross do so that was that was really
cool that was another good thing about
he pops out from under the sheet with
the gun like yeah that in a movie not
about money shots that was a very money
money shot and this movie knew the right
times to like give you a little
satisfaction yeah for sure it's not that
kind it's a very austere movie in
various ways but uh but yeah in that
sense I mean Alejandro and yatu I mean
to go from Birdman right away to this
damn impressive dude absolutely
impressive man's is on a roll well guys
leave us your thoughts on the Revenant
and oh I did like to the the little
moments I thought were well chosen for
the most part when they would do you
know some kind of classic like oh I'm
having a vision of my of my dead wife or
something like that or oh I'm flashing
back to the tree like you know in those
little moments of narration that come
back in a disperate and desperate
moments like you know the the they're
the most fantastic iCal parts of the
movie and they're the most sort of like
filmy parts of the movie or or less
naturalistic obviously but I thought
those were and Al I totally agree and
also too I like that they didn't do too
much Exposition into what happened to
his wife and you know all that they just
showed us and we we know like we know
from there we don't need Exposition so
it's just to me it's more powerful that
way decent amount of thing the right
things were ambiguous the right things
got wrapped up but what did you guys
think of of the Revenant leave us your
thoughts down below and before we
skattle let's give a little patron of
the day shout out Tyler Tyler hope
you're doing well out there in Wisconsin
and uh hey I was thinking during this
movie you know if there's anybody who
could have lightened the fraking mood
throughout all this it would have been
you my friend you know if we had you as
part of our little Trapper Brigade I
feel like everyone would just be a
little bit nicer to the earth a little
bit nicer to the people around them
maybe we don't need to scalp anybody at
all I mean I know you'd be without your
screens which is difficult but maybe
back in these times you'd have like five
Books open or something like that plus
you know if anybody goes down you're
probably strong enough to carry them
plus you know you would be able to
regail us with Tales you probably got a
million campfire stories or at the very
least just the dulet tones of your
relaxed smooth voice would bring
everybody to a state state of peaceful
calm out there in the cold you would be
the warm blanket for our party and maybe
just maybe save us all from uh you know
terrible death by the elements as well
as uh you know vindictive pain at the
hands of our Brethren you could
unify the the the the the
country Tyler HG either way I hope
you're doing well I appreciate you being
here for so long and uh for sending all
your and whatnot missed chatting with
you back in the old days of the Google
Hangouts and whatnot but it means a lot
that you're still here and uh and yeah
stay well out there hope it's not too
cold out where you are and uh we'll
catch you next month much love buddy
[Music]
cheers